le face à face à présent dans cette
édition du 7 8 ce soir c'est l'occasion
vous le savez le face-à-face d'en savoir
plus sur nos invités de connaître leur
parcours leur histoire ce soir c'est
avec dominique mocka pardon bonsoir vous
êtes le fondateur date ddm concept
société basée à saint quentin en
yvelines qui a fait a notamment parlé
d'elle en juillet elle a développé ce
kit qui permet l'autopartage sur la
twizy on va on va en revenir quelques
instants dessus justement quel est le
bilan quel bilan vous faites sur
l'autopartage de la twizy qui a été
lancée avant l'été alors déjà c'est un
beau c'est un beau bilan parce que
renault a fait confiance à une pme des
disciplines
donc ça je pense qu'effectivement
c'était déjà un atout le 13 janvier le
vendredi 13 janvier 2012 adm a signé
donc un accord pour réaliser les 50
twizy est donc
la dernière fois quand j'étais venu à
l'émission je vous avais dit qu'on avait
racheté donc une entreprise dans la
région qui avait quelques difficultés
pour réaliser entre autres des moules de
petites séries et cette société donc a
pu bénéficier tout de suite en fin de
compte d'un volume très important en fin
de compte de moulis une vingtaine de
moules la réalisation l'intégration des
50 véhicules phase est un succès story
je pense que je le dois aussi à renault
puisque je dirais de la pme apporte à
ces grands groupes la réactivité mais
c'est eux qui restent nos donneurs
d'ordres d'autres maîtres d'oeuvre ils
ont fait un travail formidable
travailler dans le secteur de
l'automobile aujourd'hui c'est pas
difficile
lendemain quand vous voyez la situation
dont nous parlions tout à l'heure avec
donc la patrie c'est henri duchesne qui
est resté sur le plateau avec toute
valeur j'imagine que vous avez été
attentif alors quel regard vous avez sur
le l'évolution du marché sur la
situation sur votre situation c'est
j'irai quand on est content dit
responsable d'une pme où on voit les
choses forcément différemment et
alors en plus quand on a été un jour
constructeur chez les constructeurs
automobiles comme moi équipementiers
petite pme et créateurs d'entreprise
aujourd'hui je rachète des entreprises
et c'est vrai que on s'aperçoit qu'en
fin de compte il ya une autre vision
des grands groupes pour une vision
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus tourné sur les
développements à l'international
une pme les tournées plutôt sûr
aujourd'hui sa région le développement
de ces équipes ce qui lui donne aussi sa
force mais aussi sa faiblesse est pour
cette raison qu il doit être absolument
à dos et un grand donneur d'ordres dans
les chiffres moi si je prends simplement
ma vie professionnelle 1980
1981 c'était une balance commerciale qui
était positif pour nous un peu plus de
55 millions d'euros
sur la balance commerciale en tout cas
de l'automobile alors que l'allemagne
était négative
aujourd'hui en tout cas vingt ans après
on se retrouve complètement l'inversé
nous on est à moins 70 à peu près et
l'allemagne est à plus 150 donc pour
quelles raisons les chiffres le montrent
de belles c'est à dire que quand j'étais
chez psa entre autres à aulnay sous bois
sur les voitures qui étaient fabriqués
chaque jour 80% de cette voiture partait
à l'étranger et donc il restait
simplement en vain 20% en france depuis
ces dernières années c'est vrai que les
volumes se sont déplacés pour installer
des usines dont forcément les vins qui
restait que pour la france voire pour
leurs offres sont pas suffisants pour
faire tourner les usines donc il faut
trouver un autre modèle donc c'est pour
cette raison qu'il ya en ce moment il
faut fermer des usines il faut au
contraire on est motivés donc c'est une
transition et dans cette transition il
me semble encore une fois c'est que le
réseau de pme n'est pas utilisé et ce
réseau de pme français aujourd'hui qui
est absolument puissant
devrait être encore plus accessible
vis-à-vis des grands donneurs d'ordre et
là je pense tout simplement que il
suffirait de pas mettre forcément les
acheteurs à acheter les produits
elle est plutôt aujourd'hui les services
techniques pour le service de
l'innovation un acheteur n'achète pas
d'innovation c'est une mise en avant par
rapport au groupe a cessé ce que vous
nous dites les pme sont pas mis en
valeur patrice andré duchesne cas quelle
analyse vous pouvez faire dessus vous
partager cela oui oui je partage ce
regard est d'ailleurs les pouvoirs
publics le partage depuis 2008 c'est que
en france on n'a pas su structurer la
filière automobile jusque là comme les
allemands ont su le faire en créant
beaucoup plus de passerelles beaucoup
plus de lieu de dialogue et de partage
entre les grands donneurs d'ordre que
peuvent être les constructeurs ou les
équipementiers de rang les grand comme
valeo et toutes les pme effectivement
créative
puissante et ingénieuse qui font la
force de cette filière en france or
depuis il ya eu une plateforme
automobile qui a été créé un début 2009
justement pour rapprocher ces mondes
enregion ça donnait lieu à la
structuration de ces associations
régionales de figure automobile que nous
sommes nous pour l'île de france et puis
vous avez les pôles de compétitivité
avec notamment chez nous moveo que vous
connaissez pas ce que je tombe vous êtes
effectivement adhérents à léran nouveau
comme année justement absolument où se
rencontrent les pme les grands groupes
leurs chercheurs est également le monde
de l'innovation puisque l'université de
versailles saint quentin et est un
partenaire de premier plan de mauvais
goût qu'elle est un petit peu votre
parcours si on parle de votre société
vous l'avez lancé à quel moment et vous
savez que ce serait difficile déjà quand
vous y être lancées dans ce
la création de la dfb 1993 j'ai fait ma
carrière professionnelle sur mes dix
premières années chez psa sur le site
d'aulnay d'ailleurs pour mettre en place
la robotisation et de cette robotisation
on m'a demandé d'aller au bureau
d'études à la direction de la
carrosserie pour essayer effectivement
de mettre en place ce qu'on appelait la
qualité totale c'était la vision globale
j'ai passé ces années je pense avoir des
fournisseurs c'est à dire que si je
parle simplement très françois trêve
c'était une toute petite pme la société
reydel c'était une toute petite mémé cap
là c'était bien 6 800 passera et
d'ailleurs et on les a rassemblés on a
essayé en tout cas de faire en sorte de
prendre celui qui était bureau d'études
celui qui allait s'occuper de
l'industriel celui et et de créer
effectivement des groupes des
groupements
quand j'ai quitté psa a été pour
reprendre un groupe en europe ariès et
dans leur part y est on a gonflé très
rapidement moi qui venais d'une boîte de
200000 personnes suis passé d'un seul
coup d'une entreprise de 1000 personnes
qui est allé jusqu'à 4000 et là on a vu
les fonds de pension anglais
ricains arrivée automotive oxford
automotive et là ça a été la catastrophe
et on ne parlait que de trésorerie et
finance et on parlait plus de technique
et de richesses humaines géré quitté
encore une nouvelle fois en désaccord
avec avec la stratégie pour reprendre
une entreprise en province
à oradour-sur-glane dans le domaine du
plastique 10 personnes et là j'ai pris
un coup de sang quand j'ai vu tomber des
presses à injecter il y avait dit prête
à injecter des pièces que je vais
dessiner chez psa qui avait été pris par
des grands donneurs d'ordre des grands
équipementiers parce que fallait la
taille critique à l'école à l'époque de
1 milliard de francs autrement les
autres sont trop nuls mais je faisais
partie j'avais cet ego là je pense que
je fais mon mea culpa parce que tant que
quand j'étais chez psa joue et ça il m'a
fallu se parcourt la limite de 17 ans
d'expérience entre la grosse la moyenne
et la petite et aujourd'hui la création
pour depuis 18 ans l'adn concept devrait
à me battre en rassemblant des pme en
inventant de nouveaux projets tels que
les fédéraux et surtout pas dépasser le
cadre de la pme dans cette nouvelle
expérience de nouveaux problèmes vous
défie vous est lancé je pense que ces
auditions dit au sein du fort st le
serbe résidence du ravi comme comme
d'autres aujourd'hui dans movéo et
d'autres associations si on a créé des
plates formes ce qui manque aujourd'hui
c'est la clé si la clé pour ouvrir les
portes pour moi la clé c'est le projet
c'était une expérience par exemple pour
twizy quand renault est venu avec sa clé
d'un seul coup ça à développer du
business donc ça veut développer des
sous traitants ça a développé de
l'intérim ça va développer et ainsi de
suite et là on rentre effectivement dans
un vrai sujet ce qui manque aujourd'hui
c'est ce type d'initiative c'est à dire
de il faut absolument alors il y en a
quelques-unes sait pas qu'il n'existe
pas mais il faut multiplier pour essayer
de faire des maillons forts qui vont
effectivement être demain des futurs
leaders et des outils que l'on cherche
tous par les c'est possible encore et
vous pouvez agir pour ça justement ben
justement la multiplication de ces
instances de dialogue déjà les gens vont
apprendre à se parler les pme légendes
et de recherche et développement des
grands groupes et plus parlerons plus
ils apprendront à se parler le plus en
amont possible de manière à être dès le
départ dans une vie lyon qui permettra
d'allier tout le monde est aussi une
autre initiative j'ai pas mentionné ces
bd comme qui va être à satory et qui va
permettre justement de réunir tout un
tas d'entreprises de la filière le plus
en amont possible pour préparer les
véhicules du futur donc j'espère
j'appelle de tous mes voeux à ce que ces
différentes initiatives à ce que move
est aussi donne justement cette habitude
du dialogue sur l'innovation le plus en
amont possible et que ça débouche sur
des projets qui permettront aux acteurs
locaux de travailler ensemble c'est le
but en tous les cas je pense que on a
évoqué le territoire et c'est vrai que
les pme sont très tournés vers leur
territoire et je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
vision des grands groupes est un petit
peu aussi en train de se tourner vers
des tissus
territoriaux là où ils sont installés la
vitrine de l'automobile ce sera le salon
de l'automobile forcément la fin du mois
de septembre vous y seraient présents
jusqu'à présent avec
buzz c'est un scoop c'est à dire que
vous voulez c'est quand qu'ils avaient
plus qu on la voit comme j'avais parlé
la dernière fois du système un système
auto partage des dykes on transforme en
une voiture en une heure
alors qu'au début il fallait quatre
heures là maintenant quand vous allez
passer cette barre locks ivre et ouvrez
le petit volet qu'il voulait ouvrir
directement avec votre téléphone
portable vous allez trouver dedans les
clés de la voiture
effectivement ils sont là vous allez
trouver dedans les cartes essence et
tout ce qui va bien et quand vous aller
refermer la pièce là on peut pas le voir
vous avez un écran vous avez l'eau
parleurs et vous avez en fin de compte
un système qui va être très sympa
implanté qu'on présente avec orange avec
un système nfc pour le mondial de
l'automobile comment ça fonctionne ça
sert concrètement toutes les voitures
peuvent être transformés par c'est à
dire que on peut très bien voilà ça
devient de plus en plus simple de
transformer de la véhicules en
autopartage et c'est un progrès des
concepts une dernière question pour
conclure la réussite des adm concept
justement c'est un bon exemple
quand j'entends une success story
qui en avait 19 ans elles sont pas assez
connus les mails sont nombreuses et dans
toutes les régions de france et quand je
vois une initiative comme celle-là on
sait qu'aujourd'hui on commence beaucoup
à parler de location de véhicules entre
particuliers c'est quelque chose qui va
se formant se développer justement on
est avec l'écueil de il faut absolument
que je reste là prennent la voiture pour
donner les clés aux gars qui va me l'a
louée pour un week-end avec ce type
d'innovation on est sur des systèmes qui
vont permettre de développer ce que je
trouve être sur le plan de développement
durable en tout cas une très bonne
initiative
merci à tous les deux d'être venu parler
aux automobiles et puis parler de votre
entreprise votre votre parcours
brièvement donc sur ce plateau avec ce
scoop avant le salon de l'automobile
wadienne concept sera présent la suite
du 7-8 consacré à cette question y
aura-t-il un effet jeux olympiques sur
les inscriptions dans les clubs sportifs
pour le moment retour sur le vaste
chantier de rénovation du centre
commercial espace saint quentin à
montigny le bretonneux avec ce reportage
l'espace saint quentin à montigny fête
ses 25 ans et pour l'occasion s'offre un
plan de rénovation à hauteur de plus de
6 millions d'euros sols plafonds parking
code couleur tout va être revu les
travaux vont débuter à la fin de l'année
pour six mois l'objectif reste est
attrayant sas à la concurrence alpha
parc de inauguré ce mardi aux
clayes-sous-bois ou la refonte de vélizy
et parler d'eux
le directeur estime disposer d'atouts
différents on a par exemple une capacité
de parking depuis 4000 places ce qui
paye qui permet de venir faire ses
courses en toute tranquillité et puis
voilà on offre aussi
un quelque chose d'atypique parce qu'on
est là voir un centre fermé et alain
centre ouvert avec une rue piétonne et
un bassin mais il faut sans cesse
innover pour continuer à attirer la
clientèle familiale et capter d'autres
clients comme les salariés qui gravitent
autour de l'espace 50 ans on n'a plus de
cent mille employés qui travaillent près
de la zone donc on va faire des offres
dédiées mais refaire des des offres
ciblées pour les sièges sociaux
notamment bouygues malakoff médéric ou
bientôt pour accueillir le siège social
de mercedes des pack de bienvenue ont
été réservées aux étudiants de la fac de
médecine tout proche l'autre défi c'est
la restructuration du voisin skywest en
quarts et privés ouest sur site
seulement 20 magasins sont ouverts sur
60 on va relancer ce site avec le projet
carré privé qui verra le jour sur la fin
de l'année 2013 et comme nous devons
lancer des travaux importants de
restructuration nous devons en fait
fermer certaines boutiques nous sommes
bien sûr on fait ça en accord avec ses
boutiques demain dans le nouvel espace
dédié au luxe à prix cassés les
habitants pourront retrouver le cinéma
un pôle restauration
le bol inouï va déménager rejoindre à
l'espace saint quentin dans les locaux
de l'ancien cinéma et il n'y aura plus
qu'une seule enseigne aux sports une
transformation qui va débuter au premier
trimestre 2013